THE ICE TONIGHT AND HE WASFENSIA
>> Cheryl: FILIP GUSTAVSSON HAS
TKACHUK, CHABOT AN
CLUTTERBUCK WILL WHISTLE THIS
ONE IN
TIME.
CHABOT LETS IT OING SOMETHING,
WRISTER DOWN LOW.
NORRIS IS ON THE DEFENSIVE SIDE.
YOU WANT TO GET TO THE FRENCH
AND CRUNCH YOUR PLAYER AS WELL.
FRONT, TKACHUK MISSINGIT, JON?
NO, HE DELIVERED WITH THAT SOME
GOOD PERIMETER PUC
THIS POINT ONSOROKIN HAS HIS NU.
>> Cheryl: OH, HUGE CHANCES FOR
SHORT BRADY TKACHUK
OFF THE SIDE.HE
TIRELESS HOURS AND THE WILL THEY
HAVE TO GET YOU RINGS FROM ANOM
PUCK GETS THROUGH
GUSTAVSSON
GLOVE.
TALK ABOUT THE RELENTLESS
PURSUIT
THE PASSING AS BELLOWS IS
FORMENTON... JUMPING DOWN.
SOMETHING, IF HE'S GOING TO GET
TO HIM, MIGHT NT
OF THE NET.
YOU TALK ABOUT PAGEAU BEING 15-4
IN THE CIRCLE.
DEVILS, TRYING TO SEE WHAT THEY
COULD DO AGAINST A RESTED
ISLANDERS TEAM, OUT OF THE BOX,
THERE.
AND FEED, AND ALEX FORMEN